what would happen if humankind became
extinct at any moment I bet that among
you lovers of the post-apocalyptic genre
will have already foretasted this
scenario whether it be by nuclear winter
a giant tidal wave as a Roland Emirates
2012. over an Unstoppable pandemic as in
The Last of Us the result however would
be similar ruined buildings devoured by
climbing plants streets occupied by car
wrecks animals and stores pillaged a
fallout-like atmosphere which writer
Alan weissmann describes in his essay
the word without us after all it's easy
to imagine a completely abandoned Urban
setting that's what we are talking about
today ghost towns they can be found
everywhere there are intact ones and
crumbling ones and as we'll see shortly
their Origins are indeed varied for
American writer Lambert Florin a ghost
town is a ghostly semblance of what it
itself used to be that's why my first
thought goes to pripyat in the Ukrainian
oblast of Kiev evacuated on April 28
1986 the day after after the well-known
Chernobyl nuclear disaster to date
radiation levels have stabilized the
thanks in part to the new protective
Arch surrounding the reactor to the
point that the site attracts tourists
from all over the world thanks to the
famous Ferris wheel and structures that
have remained literally 40 years old
well pripyat leads the way for us to
talk about the first reason why a city
should be abandoned a disaster this
expanse of Ash sand and gutted dwellings
surrounded by tropical nature is or
rather was Plymouth the capital and Main
Port of Entry to the island of
Montserrat a British overseas possession
located in the Lesser Antilles
archipelago to the South Rises the
software Hills a volcano just over one
thousand meters high that had been
dormant for centuries until it erupted
on several occasions beginning in July
1995 flooding a large area of the island
including the capital with the breeze
and pyroclastic flows two years later on
June 25 1997 a new devastating eruption
destroyed eighty percent of Plymouth
bearing it under Ash the volcanic
material Consolidated to the point that
it became unremovable except with the
help of explosives or bulldozers which
was Impractical given the cost therefore
after the British Navy ship HMS
Liverpool had evacuated the inhabitants
to other Islands including Antigua and
Guadalupe most of them chose to emigrate
to the UK or to braids the new de facto
Capital now the seat of administrative
offices officially the capital Still
Remains Plymouth awaiting the completion
of the little Bay Port in the Northwest
and what to do with the Wasteland in the
meantime montserrat's government has
clear ideas in 2016 then Premier
Donaldson Romeo declared we have learned
to live with the volcano it's time to
convert Ash into money a metaphor well
not so much as early as 2010 trucks and
bulldozers had begun removing sand from
the so-called exclusion Zone that is the
inaccessible area in blymouth to sell it
on the international market as
construction material the volcano itself
has also come in handy so much so that
between 2012 and 2017 the Island's
government drilled the three Wells for
geothermal energy extraction with
financial help from the British crown
and wants to build the fourth Facility
by 2024 writing the exclusion Zone this
has coincided with the Advent of
tourists and lovers of apocalyptic
scenarios who are interested in what is
now called the Pompeii of the Caribbean
and from the combo vacations and natural
disasters here comes a ghost Resort it's
Villa piquen a land of architectural
skeletons rotten trees abandoned luggage
and wreckage of all kinds which remained
submerged for a quarter of a century and
resurfaced only when the waters begin to
recede in the summer of 2009. beginning
in 1921 the area some 600 kilometers
away from Buenos Aires began to be
occupied by vacation homes stores clubs
and large actuary hotels and by the
1970s the huge flow of tourists
attracted by the healing properties of
lake epiquence waters brought the
picturesque Spa town to accommodate a
population of more than five thousand
everything seemed to be going well until
in November 1985 a sudden drop in
atmospheric pressure generated the
so-called assessor phenomenon that is a
periodic wave motion in the lake the
latter broke the embankment built in
1978 to protect the village and before
long the area disappeared under 3 meters
of water which then Rose to 10 in 1993.
the drought of 2009 uncovered the sum of
the salt bleached trees and structures
and among the few still intact a
magnificent slaughterhouse built by
Argentine architect Francisco Salamone
stands out but there is a second reason
that can lead the city to mutate into a
ghost town the anticipation of some
disastrous events do you know Mel
Gibson's The Passion of the Christ the
movie was shocking Krakow an ancient now
uninhabited medieval village in southern
Italy Matera Province first a huge
landslide in 1963 that forced the
inhabitants to move Downstream to
krakopesquera then a flood in 1972 that
prevented the repopulation of the old
town and finally the europeania
earthquake in 1980 transformed The
Village into a tourist attraction and
valuable movie set the same happened to
the Irish Island the settlement of great
basket inhabited for Centuries by a
small community that reached 200 people
in the early 20th century but was
evacuated permanently by the government
in November 1953 because of increasingly
extreme weather conditions fear of some
unpleasant event has also reached the
Indonesian authorities the capital
Jakarta is set to sink underwater by
2050. and this is due to the fact that
the mega City already washed by the Java
sea rests on swampy ground traversed by
as many as 13 River others it should
come as no surprise that due to frequent
flooding in 2019 the local government
announced that the construction of a new
administrative and political Center
nuzantara to be built 1 300 kilometers
away on the island of Borneo of course
this move with an estimated cost of 32.4
billion dollars brings with it
objections of various kinds from the
choice of name for the new capital to
the environmental issue related to the
deforestation of an area rich in
wildlife and rainforests but for our
purposes it would be interesting to
observe the process of jakarta's
transition from an overcrowded City
housing 10 million people into a ghost
town on closer inspection then what
defines an abandoned town is also a
sudden change in pre-existing economic
conditions those human settlements that
arise as a result of the industrial and
demographic development of a given area
such as around the factory system or a
mine take the name boom towns think of
our Urban centers such as Manchester and
the Liverpool which arose during the
Industrial Revolution or kiruna in
Lapland created in 1900 by the Swedish
Kingdom to exploit the nearby mine which
today supplies 80 percent of the Iron
Mine in Europe in the 1970s as the mine
expanded both above and below ground
several neighborhoods in the town were
cleared and incorporated into the
expanding site after all this is also
the inevitable fate of any Village in
the proximity of any deposit at the
moment the Swedish government in order
to prevent the prosecution of excavation
which is already responsible for several
landslides in the ground and collapse of
structures from endangering the safety
of the inhabitants is implementing an
ambitious and expensive plan to
physically move and reassemble elsewhere
some 3000 structures 65 percent of the
buildings in the entire town and what
happens if the activity around which a
Boomtown River dogs suddenly ceases the
example of the California town of Bodhi
is Illuminating we are in the areas
bordering the Sierra Nevada mountain
range where huge amounts of gold were
discovered beginning in the second half
of the 1800s in 1859 a man named William
or Wakeman body discovered the rich gold
deposit about 16 kilometers from monobil
and there founded body a modest town of
just a few houses about 20 Miners and
almost irrelevant mining activity this
was because news of the discovery didn't
spread far until Quebec seat to the
rapid development of the huge Comstock
load mines in Virginia City and Aurora
when these deposits were later exhausted
Bodhi experienced its moment of Glory
coming to be home to some 10 000
inhabitants between 1879 and 1980.
dozens of saloons brothels opium dance
and a small Chinatown eventually earning
its reputation as Shooter's town because
of the frequent gunfight fights on the
city streets in the early 1900s mining
began to decline and the mine closed its
doors for good in 1913 leading to a
rapid decline in profits until even the
Bodhi and Benton railroad slowly became
unused the 50 kilometer rail line that
linking Bodhi to monomials ensured the
mining town a steady supply of lumber a
series of adverse circumstances that led
residents to abandon the area in 1942
and since 1962 Bodhi has been a tourist
attraction in a state of Arrested Decay
consisting of Dusty wooden buildings
wrecked Chevrolet and rusting electric
generators the same fate happened to
many other outposts that sprang up
during the Gold Rush period but don't
think that places devoted to various
Manning activities escaped it the most
problematic case is surely that a Witten
home a former mining town in Western
Australia that has earned the unpleasant
nickname of the most contaminated site
in the southern hemisphere in fact the
20 20 000 people who live there were
evacuated in 1978 because the mining of
crossy delight the deadliest type of
asbestos from 1943 to 1966 contaminated
the soil led to the deaths of hundreds
of people and increased the risk of
developing respiratory diseases and
Cancers and over time efforts to clean
up and remove 3 million tons of toxic
waste haven't produced the desired
results an exclusion zone of 50 000
hectares of land is mentioned but
according to the Australian government
the estimate could be even worse another
deserted place is Coleman's Cup in
southern Namibia a German architectural
style settlement located on that portion
of the Namib Desert that the German
government in the early 1900s classified
as a spergy beat reserved area dedicated
to Diamond exploration in 1954 the
diamonds ended and with them so did the
mining today the desert has reclaimed
its dominance over houses dense Halls
casinos and even Africa's first Tramway
then taking a huge leap North for the
latitude we find a very unique Boom Town
Ramadan an old Swedish Outpost dating
back to 1910 located in a Norwegian
archipelago of zwalbard and intended for
cool production it was donated to the
Soviet Union in 1927 becoming the second
Russian outpost on the larger island of
spitzbergen along with the barrensburg
Outpost this mall two square kilometer
urban center operating under the control
of Soviet mining giant Arctica was home
to a community of Russian miners for
decades and its 60 kilometers of mine
shafts continue to operate until the
early 1990s but reduced production
combined with the costs and Logistics
required to maintain such a settlement
in such a prohibitive location led to
its final closure in 1998. coal mining
was also conducted on Ashima also called
gunkanjima literally worship Island
because of the distinct active shape
given to it by the concrete and still
buildings there and located about 20
kilometers away from the port of
Nagasaki Japan in 1959 an area of just a
6.4 hectares came to house
5259 people recording the highest
population density in history to date
not bad for a coal mine on the water
that closed its doors forever in 1974
when Mitsubishi decided to focus on oil
as an energy source another remarkable
ghost Village is surely fordlandia lost
in the Amazon rainforest the birthplace
of this town was in 1928 Henry Ford
himself who had decided to look there
for a source of cheap latex to bypass
the Sri Lanka rubber Monopoly maintained
by Britain securing a direct and
alternative source of material for
making tires this would contain the
production costs of the new model A cars
the investment wouldn't only have
economic but also social significance
because it can married with it Ford's
desire to perform what was later called
a work of civilization aimed at helping
to develop that wonderful and fertile
land good intentions however had to
contend with the difficulty of
standardizing the cultivation of rubber
trees because planting them too close
together made them exposed to disease
and pests in addition The Chosen side
made it difficult to transport the raw
materials and facilitated water
stagnation an ideal environment for the
spread of malaria to make matters worse
despite the high salaries worker
discontent due to the rigid work rhythms
that followed the assembly line
philosophies resulted in Revolt in
December 1930. in the end the fordlandia
was all took no action as in 1945 Ford's
grandson was forced to sell off the land
to Brazil to cut down the rising costs
the company was facing at that time
World War II had come to an end we all
know about the day don't we the Normandy
Landings which took place on June 6 1944
on the French Coast according to the
British Operation Overlord wouldn't have
been possible without tynheim a small
fishing Village in Dorset that died for
England a year before The Landings in
1943 the British government confiscated
it to allow Allied Forces to train on
terrain considered the similar to what
they would find upon arrival on the
continent even if Churchill assured the
residents that they would be able to
return to their homes when hostilities
ceased in 1948 with the Cold War looming
it was decided to prioritize defensive
needs and so the state took over tynheim
once and for all today the village is
owned by the ministry of defense and is
part of the lulworth firing ranges which
is why the area can only be visited by
tourists by special permit moving to the
other side of the English Channel four
days after the Normandy Landings on June
10 1944 a battalion of 200 Nazi soldiers
rounded out the inhabitants of the small
village of oradorsurglan under the guise
of a simple identity check and carried
out a massacre Burning Alive 642 people
including nearly 200 children and
setting fire to houses Barns and garages
the real motivation for the massacre was
the kidnapping of an SS Commander near
limosh about 20 kilometers away of this
costly place today you would find only
crumbling buildings and a museum
commemorating the tragic event and
indeed unfortunately war is one of the
main generators of ghost towns either
directly or indirectly by simple cruelty
or military interests take the case of
varosha once a booming tourist District
of the cypriot city of famagusta which
at its peak was home to 39 000 residents
and which after the invasion of Cyprus
by the Turkish military in July 1974
became home to decaying buildings and
crumbling hotels cradled by a desolate
beach in fact in the aftermath of the
invasion the local Greek cypriot
population fled and since then no one
has set food there again except the
Turkish military of course since today
the area belongs de facto to the
Republic of Turkey in late 2020 however
the Turkish government which is pressing
for international recognition of
Northern Cyprus announced an initiative
to revive the old tourist town until
recently unoccupied and classified as a
military zone in one year some 400 000
civilians would visit it in last October
ercintatar president of the self
proclaimed the Turkish Republic of
Northern Cyprus announced that varosha
would also house public buildings and
there you have it depending on the
interests of the moment Beyond tourism
one can imagine that a ghost town could
be repopulated and returned to full
operation then we have the phenomenon of
ghost towns in China which is quite
unique let me explain let's consider
kangbashi in China's inner Mongolia
autonomous region about 560 kilometers
west of Beijing it's part of ordo's
prefecture which has a total population
of 2 million and together with the urban
core of dongseng is one of the two
largest municipalities the original plan
was to build the Boom Town capable of
housing 1 million people a number later
scaled back to 300 000. most of whom
would work in the nearby coal mines to
be precise the idea was to make kangbash
in a new administrative Center of ardo's
prefecture and government offices
medical facilities and schools would be
relocated to nearby dongsang during its
first to five years of construction
which began in 2004 a large number of
commercial buildings a museum and even
an opera house were built but already
the name of ghost town was beginning to
spread according to reports initially
almost no one wanted to move to the new
town because there were few jobs and no
common facilities so every working day
people were forced to commute between
kangabashi and dongsang the reality we
are witnessing today is that a new and
expanding town is not quite empty but
rather in 2016 boasted a substantial
daytime population 100 000 people of
whom 80 percent were full-time residents
not a bad result when compared to
Chinese housing standards even so photos
show as endless rows of buildings with
no apparent sign of human life this is
because there is a real culture of real
estate investment in China due to the
widespread belief that this is the best
way to generate and preserve the wealth
what on the surface might look like
derelict cities are instead simply
unoccupied then filled with new housing
units purchased as Investments also made
by taking advantage of government
benefits and remaining unoccupied by
owners or tenants think that in all of
China there are about 50 municipalities
that are practically unoccupied in
proportion to their housing capacity
which translates into 50 million homes
without tenants according to reports by
the South China Morning Post the problem
is that the housing sector is a pillar
of China's economy worth about a quarter
of all the country's economic output
some believe there is a housing market
bubble that is a phenomenon of rising
house prices which could collapse and
bring the entire National economy into
the abyss Financial uncertainty is
already affecting ever Grande one of the
real estate development Giants which has
depths of 300 billion dollars and has
about 1.6 million unsold Apartments this
is the result of Decades of failed urban
planning projects the highest expression
of which is the 9 billion Dollars theme
park left to rot in the city of Luan
located 500 kilometers west of Shanghai
along with an electric car factory that
never went into operation and there you
have it the Genesis of a
post-apocalyptic scenario even before an
apocalypse despite everything Xi Jinping
sent to Raj continues to come Mission
ambitious Urban projects such as shongan
a new futuristic hyper technological
urban area Southwest of Beijing and all
we have to do is wait to see if the
Communist party's Visions will bear
fruit or prove unsuccessful another
matter that is unclear to me is related
to Napier though the capital of Myanmar
since November 6 2005. the king's
residence that is the meaning of the
name is located in the middle of the
Jungle is six times the size of New York
City cost 4 billion dollars has eight
Lane roads luxury hotels 30 government
buildings protected by a ditch a giant
golden Pagoda and four huge golf courses
spectacular on the surface I wonder
however where its lifeblood is since it
can get to a million in evidence the
most certain thing at the moment is that
the former capital Yangon which is about
300 kilometers away Remains the de facto
cultural and spiritual center of the
country making the glitzy napido and
mere white elephant oh I forgot at least
those huge roads were used for an
episode of Top Gear that's something and
with this last example we have come to
the end of our journey of discovery of
grim and peculiar places I'm sure I've
forgotten many other ghost towns so let
me know what other places you think are
worthy of inclusion within this spooky
list thank you all for your attention
and we'll see you in the next video ciao